where are you from you were the scariest
Asian do that met my life yeah mostly
tattoos - oh we just went over this man
Hawaiian Oh you're Hawaiian you're
Samoan okay you know Simone Hawaiian
Asian with sugar that's what you got
another agent to one's head sugar that's
what I should have been you guys are
really sensitive about historical [ __ ]
yeah I don't care how much stevia you
use you still have using the sugar
organic a sprout are you also Hawaiian
okay his education really pushed in
Hawaiian culture do they need you guys
to be doctors okay use a good laugh or
they give it for you your doctors anyway
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
it feels SC
if you want into a double I can see them
all those ones got to stand up
you stand up real pretty look at this
dude look at this man look at this guy
if he walks in to your doctor's office
[Applause]
what kind of doctor Kyra prayers not a
doctor
get over on these I mean you don't know
what doctors are
Neal is a wobbler who when rocky start
from the spine
how's a guy who uncle's was a doctor I
was like no you literally use like this
gotta be easier way to do this sure that
makes sense I can see you being in
college and then being like did I study
for this test or get another tattoo we
don't want to do okay the feels like a
surgeon humanity walks into your office
are you like you walk into office and
then that's the guy you see I feel like
are you the bodyguard for the real
doctor this make any sense are you also
a chiropractor you guys haven't
practiced together I don't know if you
call it a practice you guys have a
office together oh no not yet okay
are you also chiropractor though yeah
okay you guys make a lot of money not
really helping people I know you know
some people my mom had a chiropractor
and I really helped her but like the
majority pretend yeah they pretend
they're better and then two weeks later
like how does she get worse
[Music]
okay well you said you're a doctor
you're a doctor of placebos see if you
don't hurt me after the show please but
if you do I'm gonna come see you and ask
you to fix it
you won't but I'm gonna make you doing